Thank You Darla why would anybody ever
eat anything besides breakfast food
people are idiots largely
[Music]
come back to work no come back I want
you to come back well I don't want to
come back the end I was talking to Andy
about you and he made me realize that I
need you back at work what did he say
don't recall fine I'll come back good
okay
I'm leaving bye Zuzu
bye Duke silver my mom has all your
albums I recognized you the day we met
have you told anyone no good girl you
just grab the toilet paper I don't roll
with a little bit like this throw it on
the truth this is for mayor Percy this
is for the party department office this
is for pooping on the handball courts
this is really fun but I don't condone
it
here on can I ask you a question sure
it's about April I don't like to get
involved in people's personal I hurt her
feelings and now she's pissed at me I
feel like if I could just explain myself
she'd understand
but she's avoiding me it's making me
miserable April's in the hospital sick
with the flu
I knew it I didn't know that is she okay
yeah she's fine you can go visit her
tomorrow morning but don't tell her I
told I won't no no no okay everybody the
Harvest Festival is tomorrow and I am so
proud of all of you you've worked so
hard you're amazing so I have a surprise
and it is possibly the best thing to
potentially ever happen to anyone
anywhere in the history of the universe
ladies and gentlemen the world-famous
lil Sebastian what lil Sebastian made
his debut at the last harvest festival
in 1987 and he was an instant phenomenon
for the next few years
Sebastian was the number one boy's name
in Pawnee and the number three girl's
name
well actually I think it's good that
Chris showed up cuz I wasn't thinking
clearly I love my job Ben loves his job
and it's just not worth the risk
oh hey hey Chris just wanted me to drop
off these receipts oh well he's not here
he took off
uh-oh oh man I love this song
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what is this not my dream playing a show
the greatest band ever that's my guitar
you bought it back from sewage Joe I
actually stole it from his office but
whatever he's a weirdo maybe April
doesn't think that were the greatest
band in the world but man she loves me
and I love her so who cares
[Music]
marry
[Music]
[Applause]
we're only gonna do it later
[Applause]
what are you doing here we're here for
the club there was last week yeah that's
us today are you tough as nails would
you rather sleep on a bed of pine
needles than a mattress do you find
video games pointless and shopping malls
stupid do you march to the beat of your
own drummer did you make the drum
yourself if so you might just have what
it takes to be a Swanson pawnees most
hardcore outdoor club starts today boys
and girls welcome Swanson's are you
prepared for whatever lies ahead yes sir
before we proceed do any of you have any
dietary restrictions correct you do not
first outing is right now I will be
teaching you to dig a proper trench does
that sound like something you want to do
yes sir
this will be no fun at all
[Music]
bro
when streams are ripe and swelled with
rain
ladies and gentlemen we are gathered
here today to Mary and Maxwell Dwyer and
April Roberta led gate I guess I kind of
hate most things but I never really
seemed to hate you so I want to spend
the rest of my life with you is that
cool yes is it my turn
yes April you're the most awesome person
I have ever known in my entire life I
vow to protect you from danger I don't
care if I have to fight an Ultimate
Fighter or a bear or him your mom I
would take him down I'm getting mad
right now even thinking about it telling
you today I want to spend the rest of my
life every minute with you and I'm the
luckiest man in the galaxy and now the
Rings
by the power vested in me by the state
of Indiana I now pronounce you husband
and wife
[Applause]
[Applause]
mine we decide to throw you a pizza
party to say congrats for cracking the
case oh my god you guys this is what we
got here
wait a second that's not pizza those are
calzone no I'm good safe to say I made
the right choice
[Applause]
lemonade please and thank you hey I'm
sorry if I was Curt earlier I'm a single
mom and sometimes things get chaotic
around here when you shut up from the
parts typologies I understand completely
this is delicious I got it from food and
stuff so that's where I got these gloves
right so how exactly are you gonna fix
this hole just for my own edification I
dug the loose gravel out of the hole now
I'm using a jackhammer to remove the
larger pieces then I'll spray down the
hole to settle the dust and fill it with
cold patch asphalt well thank you now I
can fix the next one myself Ron and
Diane sitting in a tree KSS is is I PPI
yeah Bert
[Music]
you can ask for help
[Music]
it's so much more beautiful than I could
have ever even imagined yeah trying to
find a way to be annoyed by it but
coming up empty thank you so much I
never would have ever done this without
you thank you
where's all the faces at the president
you